hello brian pollak we do and you asked
me what keeps me motivated today I would
say that my faith that I'm doing what I
was meant to do I'm a fulfilling my
personal mention i left a lot of things
behind when I was 40 and it was not I
was already someone who was my friends
are getting ready to retire but I was
dreaming of being a writer since you
will end and I said no I'm going to
click everything and we're going to
start writing which I did I wrote my
first book when I was four years old
when people consider you've already
retiree as I said before and then I
start writing for Hodges my personal
data I'm a trainer and jay-z still keeps
a much better today so why missed you as
enthusiastic as I was 23 years ago and
I'm doing something that for me to think
that my work my mission my life thank
you very much better question bro